la principal sospechosa en manos de las
autoridades una mujer kurdo Siria es
señalada de ser presuntamente la autora
del atentado que se saldó con varios
muertos y decenas de heridos en Estambul
la persona que llevó a cabo el incidente
la que dejó la bomba ha sido detenida
por la policía de esta noche Turquía
culpó las milicias kurdas de gpg en
covani una ciudad del norte de Siria que
es objetivo militar de los turcos no
obstante el líder kurdo de la región más
de un abdi ha negado cualquier
implicación
afirmamos que nuestras fuerzas no tienen
nada que ver con el atentado de Estambul
y rechazamos las acusaciones que acusan
a nuestras fuerzas de ello expresamos
nuestras más sinceras condolencias a las
familias y al pueblo Turco y deseamos
una pronta recuperación a los heridos Y
es que Turquía sostiene que las milicias
kurdas de Siria son un grupo terrorista
con vínculos con el partido de los
trabajadores de kurdistán enemigo del
ejecutivo Turco algo que ha tensado
incluso sus relaciones con Estados
Unidos
rechazamos las condolencias de la
embajada estadounidense no las aceptamos
nuestra Alianza con este estado que
envía dinero de su propio senado para
estos grupos fomentando los grupos de
Cobán y que quieran perturbar la paz de
Turquía está en una situación
controvertida
a pesar de que la autoría del crimen
Todavía no se ha esclarecido el atentado
ha causado conmoción en el país y miedo
a que este tipo de ate se conviertan en
algo habitual de Cara a las elecciones
de junio de 2023 en las que recepta Jeep
erdogan podría perder por primera vez
tras dos décadas en el poder